i'm gonna tell you my favorite story of
the day so far
has been my favorite story today so far
is a real life loving basketball did you
see on good morning america
that maya moore announced that she and
jonathan
irons the man that she stepped away from
the her basketball career for two years
and counting for two years
yes from in her prime from to help free
from a wrongful
imprisonment he had served 23 years in
prison
she fought to get him freed he was a
long-time family friend
and now they are married they've already
been married
she met so she freed this man
and then saved his life as you and i
know as married men
you talked about it yesterday how much
marriage made you a better and more
complete person
this is beautiful look at god this is
biblical michael this is biblical yes it
is
we're preaching him from prison or to
free him from prison
and then they got married this is
incredible
this is incredible i was like oh my god
what a story
oh i will make the rough places plain
i'll make them straight okay
come on now i'll go ahead and preach
from isaiah really go ahead michael
smith
but but really maya moore is a superhero
anyway so before this because a lot of
people
will talk about not judging anybody but
i'm saying a lot of people will talk
about
a cause that is very important to them
that is close to their hearts
and what they're willing to give up she
was about it
she gave up her career now we're not
talking about
uh an okay player we're not talking
about a marginal player we're talking
about a star
player in the wnba she gave up her
career
because in in pursuit of how about do
you wanna talk about biblical in pursuit
of righteousness
can i get an amen all right justice amen
she is able she's able to see this
moment right here which is a beautiful
moment
and now they're married it's love
oh you know i mean this is this is
really this is really what what
marriage this is what marriage is about
it's not just about that wedding
it's about going through things together
it's about growing together absolutely
yes uh so i mean i yeah congratulations
to the newlyweds awesome i'm not i'm not
i'm not
nobody's here to power rank activism
but if you want to talk about the
athlete who's made the greatest
sacrifice
especially relative to their standing
it's by far maya moore
it's by far my amore i mean
unfortunately obviously colin
kaepernick's career was taken
from him for for his peaceful protest
and a lot of athletes have laid a lot on
the line so again i'm not power ranking
and
or but she literally walked away at the
height of her career
right to in the pursuit of justice and
righteousness and freedom for this
family friend
people constantly asking her when you're
coming back she's like i'm focused on
freeing this man
and come to find out she finds her soul
mate in the process
look full disclosure so she said this on
gmail to robin roberts
whose production company rockin robin
along with
espn films is doing a documentary about
this
they noticed they gave them a movie they
gave them a love story
this is incredible what they have an
opportunity to do and again i
i wasn't invested in it because i like
many people wanting to tell her story
and look of course remember robin
roberts understandable
you know but i mean when i saw this i
was like wow can't go wrong there
right yeah you cannot write a better
script than what we did than what we're
seeing here what did i mean i was i was
touched i was moved
it is my it's my favorite story in a
long time i'm happy for her i know this
young woman
i know her family when i say my man
you want to talk about a blessing so
he's he has 23 years of his life taken
away from him because he's wrongly
accused and put in prison
and on the other side god sends this
woman into his life
when i tell when i tell you i mean maya
moore
she is as talented as she is as
beautiful as she
is her heart and her soul and you saw it
in the sacrifice she made
he i mean he came out a winner at the
end of this
to find this woman if that's what it
took and i'm not look i don't mean to
trivialize
23 years behind bars but i'm saying he
was blessed on the other side of that
tribulation for sure
yeah i mean already mike you talk about
telling her story
uh and a lot of people know her story
for those who don't
it is worth reading up on her really
learning about her just
a phenomenal a phenomenal athlete and a
phenomenal person
you know going back years too i mean she
at
connecticut she was a great i mean an
incredible
college player at uconn great nba wnba
player
and look at what she's done here so uh
and and you know what
she's not done i mean she's still a
young woman i i look forward to seeing
what she's going to accomplish
what she's going to do going forward
because this is somebody she's a she's a
rare she's a rare breed
now this is yeah no it is i'm with you
yeah well she probably does she probably
does come back
no i'm saying but if she comes back i
mean she certainly we'll see and she
says right now she's just breathing
she's in the moment she's just
decompressing from this journey
but the other thing is jonathan not
surprisingly
they're working in tandem so she he's
coming out
and he's continuing the work to uh you
know with with legislation and reform
and voting
and civic engagement like she he is now
in the trenches with her doing the type
of life-changing work that helped to
save his life and get him free from
prison
he's now side by side not only are they
together together but they're together
in this fight so it's just
phenomenal story man really is a
phenomenal story
you